thank you for the european business
summit
for organizing this important gathering
distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen i am a medical
doctor by training
and i have always been proud of europe's
health systems
they are among the best in the world
yet the challenge of this pandemic is
unprecedented in modern times we now
know
that defeating this virus is possible
but no country and no government can
defeat this virus alone
this is true first of all at the global
level
secondly inside europe and thirdly
between the public
and the private sectors
let me focus first on our response to
the pandemic
the european union has taken the lead to
convene a global
response to covet 19 and not only a
national one
for this purpose we not only work with
who and the g20
but also with civil society and
foundations
and other private players our common
goal
is to finance the development of
vaccines
tests and treatments for the whole world
we so far raised 16 billion euros
we also joined and contributed to the
kovacs facility
to ensure that newly developed vaccines
are also available for low and middle
income countries
team europe alone has provided 800
million euros
and this is the largest donation to
covax worldwide
why have we done that because we are
convinced
that we will only defeat the virus if we
defeated all around the world
secondly we have established an
unprecedented cooperation inside europe
on health issues
in november we have taken the first
steps
to establish a european health union
we will now have an eu-wide preparedness
and response plan
this will help us harmonize national
plans
including audits and stress tests by the
european commission
we want to make it possible to declare
if necessary a state of eu health
emergency and this would trigger
greater coordination among member states
it would trigger joint procurement of
medical equipment
and for example the deployment of eu
outbreak
assistance teams to better support
member states
we also propose to give more
responsibilities
and thus powers and resources
to our existing european agencies
the european center for disease
prevention and control
ecdc and the european medicines agency
emma to improve our forecast
we will create a new agency the european
health
emergency preparedness and response
authority
it's a very long name we call it hera
here i will focus on next crisis and if
possible avert them
so here i will work with all the
relevant players
from conception to deployment of
therapies vaccines and technologies
this kind of cooperation is essential to
a rapid response
in the event of a health emergency
governments alone cannot end this
pandemic
and that's why the commission presented
last week its pharmaceutical strategy
it is about creating win-win situations
with the private sector but we also want
to put
patience at the center of medicine's
development
and supply and thus we will be working
with
innovative small companies as well as
large multinationals in europe
europe can take the lead in supplying
groundbreaking medicines
that are also affordable and widely
available
these are three cornerstones of our new
health policy
and we will continue to build the health
union in the coming months
with our beating cancer plan and the
european health data space
together with global partners together
with all the europeans
and together with the private sector
only together
will we be able to address the biggest
challenges
for global health and this leads me to
the last point
as one expert at johns hopkins put it
vaccines don't save lives vaccinations
do
the development of vaccines has been a
remarkable
team effort but we will need an
even greater effort to deliver them to
every
village of this world and we have to
prove
the safety and the efficacy of those
vaccines
especially in the face of growing
vaccine skepticism
and disinformation campaigns
and the message is clear vaccination
is about self-protection and solidarity
dear guests of the european health
summit
we have to build strong and trustworthy
narratives and this is possible
because together we have made
unprecedented progress
in the area of vaccines and this
is the result of joint cooperation
count on your further support thank you